yeah good to go hey i don't see where
what happened to your eyes
well it's well yes it's early gotta do
daddy well i've been wake up early
though i've been up since six how come
you still swell because i usually work
out by now and flush all whatever is
going on out you know oh by going out is
it all this the the
sad whiskey that you're taking no i
haven't drank whiskey in a little second
oh is that right no what what are you
maybe i'm trying to think once last time
i haven't had whiskey this week yet what
drugs do you take besides nicotine
that's it right now is that it that's it
now you actually showed up to the
concert last night which i was surprised
i showed up at the concert last night
mark harley can sing
lil brows is great i i don't i don't
know from rap so i don't know but our
boy channel is talent our boy chin has
got a love of a voice and had the whole
place mesmerized now here's the thing
that sound system can eat a dick yeah
yeah i thought it was gonna be the best
oh was it
[Applause]
i'm going to go bad on the troubadour
for a second okay i'm sorry go for it i
love these venues but you got to pay
cash to get a ticket
what thanks for watching cash yeah only
cash well does the armenian mafia run it
probably cash in 2022 then the bathroom
smelled so bad
that if you got within 30 feet of that
place like do better clean the bathroom
whatever's going on with that i felt so
bad for the bouncer i'd stand there well
chin just so you know i don't know how
tickets i heard it was actually a pretty
good showing but
in comedy if they do just cash like if
you're doing merch you do just cash
you're cutting your audience in half of
course like it royally screws you dude
like you're not that wasn't set up for
success and then the sound system like i
wanted to see your voice was great but
it was the sound system can't be tinny
it's like guys you got to fix the sound
but did you know this going into like
you did sound checks right we changed
them i don't have enough time to do
sound checks so i didn't do sound check
what do you mean we did uh because we
had so many artists and then they were
setting up the bands for chappelle so
everyone had to do a sound check chan
i'm going to use a word yeah
that that's an amateur move right yes
you can't do that we couldn't do it
though
who who had a sound check what do you
mean like
chappelle's band now
doesn't need they don't need sanchez he
yells in the mic yeah here's the thing
chin that would be like my opener or
feature doing the sound check and i
don't get to i know i know but that's
what the venue did
yeah i would no
it's a little bit on you guys that's
okay that's that's you'll learn next
time you don't do that again yeah no
pictures allowed so kyle couldn't come
no no pictures or that you have to pay
extra for that like two grand or
something let's get away from the
troubadour right the troubadour is no
good and i couldn't hear myself too i
was like i'm like hey you know pictures
no picture or like so i'm trying to take
pictures from my iphone which i got some
decent ones but like professional
pictures chin you know what you guys
need is a manager
i mean we're just you know we're just
having fun right now
you need somebody you need where it's
not you or little brows or chapelle to
call the venue like what do you mean
what do you mean no pictures no no and
cash no in soundcheck we're gonna do the
date what are you doing they're gonna be
there [ __ ] they're gonna go in at 11
a.m do the sound check and then they'll
come back yeah let me add one more to
that list too so all the pre-sale
tickets they tell you when you're about
to purchase a ticket you have to show a
vaccine card
so i'm sure people didn't want to come
because of that crap too yeah you gotta
i'm on fire
the troubadour is probably not the place
for you there are other places but we
had a great tournament all due respect
to the trooper i'm sure it's a great
venue and yeah i'll respond i like
anybody i like any venue that that hosts
music and everything else but that i
know suck this that place needs to be a
little bit we screwed our boys over yeah
it needs to be it needs to be managed a
little bit differently that's all how
they house you so i go up and
uh with a couple people with juana and
griffin and like
griffin
uh
dr gaines the chiropractor who who did
the tough mudder with us
thick kid himself yes thick boy he works
out with michael hearn now at gold so
yeah venice but anyway so they go up and
they pay you know we're like doing the
cash cash okay but i'm on the list and
she's like no mark here and then like
the guys are like like i'm like hey i'm
you know they're like we don't care man
you gotta get the thing from the thing
and come over here you know so there's
like this 15 minute thing where i'm like
just humiliated because you're like i'm
performing in there and nobody like and
i believe you have
um but you have a deep you have a very
big you have a baritone voice look if
you're around your voice i do a couple
of musicals in in college
no solos but you know sing this no more
giants no more giants you know what's
going on it's early too it is early so
the voice is
i might as well be the one
dance like this
yeah
i like that there are other songs for
you with your deep voice
with brian's help you could be the best
just we're unrealistic we're just shitty
managers hey mark with our help you
could be the best part so i'm ford
i think we really
i enjoy singing i know i'm not good at
it but like i don't even sing songs my
favorite of my favorites i get a 40 year
i've had this i've had a very successful
banker it was 40 something
and i'm not kidding he he goes uh i ran
into him in new york and he goes hey
i go hey and he's really rich and he
goes i'm gonna get into acting
[Music]
my instinct was to say
you're out of your mind but i went
that's a great idea
you know i heard the same thing my my
financial advisor in denver when i last
time i talked to him like how's it going
he's like dude it's great you know we
just sold the company but you know i got
this much money my god you're balling
dude my because yeah i'm still doing
stand-up he's 50. you don't start doing
stand-up moment
no my you know and i went hell yeah man
i don't have enough i got one way better
oh yeah i got more batteries i'm friends
have you ever done it he was knowledge
better better late
i got one way better my friend my friend
calls me because my wife he's he's like
his wife is 40 something he goes dude my
wife i want i want to pick a brain and i
really ask you a favor i go what he goes
my wife wants to get in the stand up i
go
oh because yeah she's honestly dude
she's funny she has she has us laughing
i mean she's you know she's got she's
got quirky you know she's quirky and
probably maybe not our sense of humor i
go uh huh and he goes would you would
you take she did a five minute thing
would you take a look at it i go i go
let me think i go here's the thing i go
absolutely not absolutely
yeah i go i go because i have yeah i
already i can tell you right now
that that it's she's terrible and that's
okay i go she's terrible and he started
laughing i go but that's a fact right
that's a fact
but i'll tell you what have her do it
for 10 years but write every day yeah
and in 10 years i would be happy to look
at it because it won't make a difference
anyway and maybe she'll be great maybe
do you never use openers like
like local cities do you ever use
openers sometimes hit or miss it's
going to say what city but we had this
guy very hit famous you can usually tell
like right when they come in that as
you're talking them if it's going to go
well or not yeah skype comes in and
we're just talking and you know he's
like throwing out like these big name
references and i'm like oh cool and he's
a little older and you know he's like
your dad right my yeah two kids he's
like yeah i'm a dad too man i'm like
cool cool and then he's talking i'm like
something seems off i go how long have
you been doing stand-up videos eight
years eight years well i took five years
off so you but eight years told i went
well three that would be three and he
goes well no
yeah
on stage three i'm like yeah well three
he's like
yeah i guess but eight
sure eight yeah have fun have fun this
is my brush from every show
i can take what happens i can hang with
it if you come back here the crowd is
tight too am i right dude walk in and go
just they're they're tight man they're
tight
every show they're tight
but then you'd watch everyone do really
well and then just had no awareness like
i don't think it's a crowd dude yeah you
gotta you gotta know
it just takes a long [ __ ] time it's
like and also i've had uh
young guys say hey can you watch me and
you know and i always say and then i go
it doesn't matter if you're like it
wouldn't you if i like you if i don't
like you it doesn't matter you don't
need my approval yeah you the audience
helps from your last year you know what
they actually need to let you know but
you you know you want to approve it from
your peers especially an older guy very
rarely i'll say somebody who's been
doing it a long time but very rarely
i'll see somebody and i say this to him
i go um you could be really good take
yourself seriously that's all i say you
said that to chappelle i said that she
said to me yep you're two for two yep
yep yep depends who yes might be one for
two no
i mean it's such a subjective thing but
you know the fact of the matter is if
you're making people laugh
that's that's a big thing if you're
putting butts in seats you're making
people laugh
that's the game
well also also like you know it's a
little bit like
a lot of people and i was this way too
you know you're funny you make your
friends laugh but but you when you got
to do 20 minutes just 20 minutes 30
minutes it's an eternity and you better
have a map for where you're going you
can't just get up and
d
no like you had the family barbecue chin
what what songs did you sing last night
did you do you did standing do you do
standing o did you
is that his number one hit right now
that was his number one hit before now
he has a country
he's killing it right now he can write
oh yeah god he writes like like for the
thick boy album
you know jelly roll is a guy who sleeps
in you know he writes at night he'll
write stay up to like four or five in
the morning so he sleeps during the day
and
little brown's like man can you hit up
jelly dude he still hasn't put in his
feature blah blah so i hit up jail like
yo man the album's due tomorrow dude we
still need your you know your hook or
your you know your part he's like oh you
got it bubba
wrote it in i don't know 30 minutes
sent it did it sent it in like holy [ __ ]
yeah and it is fire yeah like jesus dude
dude yep
so yeah so what songs do you do chin you
did the jelly roll cover yeah and then i
did earnest um
flower shops and then we did just like
the originals from thick boy and from
king instinct which one
of erin okay
and then love that filmed with one with
jelly roll bill is my favorite song of
all time so we did originals bry we did
originals you didn't do your originals
i did built built
we all
literally my favorite song
really i sent it to the group chat mark
i said this is my theme yeah yeah you
saying it last night
so they wrote this on clearly about your
thick friend here but um it's literally
the
the soundtrack to my special everything
yeah
little brows with jelly rolls and jelly
roll wrote this in 30 minutes get ready
and chin
[Music]
if things don't go my way i just get up
and go change it i'm talking about ten
thousand hours of plus when in tears and
they all wanna talk but they're not even
is this jelly roll singing that's a
little browse
you'll hear jelly gear
you'll come up after ten thousand
dollars
they don't see the paint
[Music]
oh my god you kidding me i didn't get
that this was you what you were singing
because i couldn't hear it i know the
mic didn't work [ __ ] [ __ ]
jelly rolls kevin you sang this last
night yeah i didn't hear it i know about
that this is the number one song on the
album
soundtrack to all my special stuff
[Music]
than the grants these amazing staples at
the same corner store that i used to
flip away i prayed for my big break but
nobody came through to get my [ __ ]
straight pushing forward every day and i
just play my part the trailer that i
used
that's basically it it's great dude
well well you know what i i
l little brows sounds great here again
the mic didn't do him justice it didn't
do him justice that was the worst sound
system i've ever heard dude i couldn't
hear you
why i didn't know that was what you were
singing i literally i didn't know if i
had heard that last night you know my
girl was loving it she she she loves
live music and she was really liking
when little brows brought that other guy
on too
there is a riley and then there's also
bobby wraps the big guy with the
height no not that guy the other guy the
first guy bobby wraps yeah he's good
he's great yeah really good but anyway
um
little the mike didn't do a little
browse any favors um i couldn't i
couldn't make out what the [ __ ] anybody
was saying so live drums is a choice
that people make which can enhance or
like with rapping it's hard because then
you're completely you can't hit like
drums
shame on all of you guys for not doing
sound
before i had to get up and go there i
want good sounds yeah
well luckily i did acoustic set so
that's something
yeah did eric griffin perform he didn't
show up i don't think oh oh okay yeah
you know oddly brian really surprised
everybody by
now yeah i mean in a good like people
were very excited yeah we were really
excited everybody was really super cool
i apologize i couldn't make it it's okay
my dad my dad ordered mediterranean food
he didn't cook he ordered mediterranean
food listen man in this current climate
prices are going up all over man but not
on your prescriptions i know it's high
but you need good rx my friends at
goodrx they got you man because you can
instantly compare prescription prices at
pharmacies in your neighborhood and find
discounts that could save you up to
eighty percent eighty percent go rx is
free and easy to use works whether you
do or do not have insurance even if you
have insurance gutter x may actually
beat your co-pay price that's right man
uh you can check the good rx online or
on the app that's what i do i use the
app you can use that over 70 000
pharmacies nationwide like cvs kroger
walgreens rite aid vaughn's walmart and
so much more
you got to do it man because you're
going to save money on prescriptions all
of us use prescriptions i use it and i
use goodrx i'm telling you it's easy
download the app and start saving right
now so for simple smart savings on your
prescriptions check goodrx go to
goodrx.com fighter that is good rx.com
fighter
goodrx.com goodrx is not insurance but
can be used in place of insurance
medicare and medicaid in 2021 goodrx
users saved 81 on retail prescription
prices go to goodrx.com fighter this
episode of the firing kit is brought to
you by our loyal our ride or die the
best supplements on the frickin planet
earth we're talking about on its
supplements whether you're at a desk
working right now you're a lawyer you're
a judge what you're an athlete you gotta
get your mind right alpha brain we're
talking about shroom tech new mood dude
we got all of it for you creatine
glutamine if you're thick but you want
me a sexy thick let anna help you man we
got nutrition we got dark roast coffee
we got proteins protein bars protein
bites we got elk bars warrior bars man
and fitness-wise you don't you don't
want to go back to the gym it's
overcrowded now everybody's going back
to the gym or you want to stay at home
and not deal with the hassle cool we
have streaming fitness home fitness
programs on a demand workouts in 30
minutes kettlebells primal bells legend
bells audit sandbags battle ropes steel
club maces what are you waiting for
on it.com fighter 10 off the entire damn
site audit.com slash fighter 10 off
you're welcome everybody
i apologize i couldn't make it it's okay
my dad my dad ordered mediterranean food
he didn't cook he ordered mediterranean
food yeah oh you know what he told me i
guess his buddies would give him [ __ ]
how i how he didn't know it was my
second special
and he goes no dummy he goes you said uh
he was of course i know it's your second
special he goes i was saying it's your
first one on your own on think boy oh
there's many more to come you're dead
and i was all [ __ ] out of you your dad
is a [ __ ] yeah your dad's a girl i feel
like oh he's so he's
you your dad and your brother
are your ride or die [ __ ] like
yeah my brother kill anybody in this
room he would kill your brother
i know
why not that's your birthday why not
dude why not i'm telling you you'd be
the first person i call if i killed
somebody i'm telling you right now
that's his big brother and his big
brother
i'm telling you right now his big
brother is one of those guys that i like
him very much but i have no doubt that
if brendan was in trouble he would kill
all of us and by the way he'd go what do
you want to eat what what's for lunch
yeah let me just get this blood off i
love jay yeah it's been really cool
you know that's the one you got to worry
about now he's the one you got to worry
about he's sick
of security enjoy that
well he's really like he's also very
calm about [ __ ] like he's like there's a
thing about him where it's like
you know he's a computer expert you know
he's he knows everything
and and he knows [ __ ] that you'd be
really surprised about yeah and he's
that quiet assassin where you're like oh
i don't know man my older brother is
saying he's a computer guy too and i
kind of like so i like immediately
respond to that energy of like
you're a step in this direction and it's
nice to have like strategic
conversations with you you know to kind
of discuss things and know you're being
very rational well jj won't leave jay
won't let you know about anything
yeah jay won't let me he won't say
anything yeah what do you mean
he'll just be like if he doesn't gossip
he doesn't entertain the house was on
fire he'd go hey what's up he'd call him
that's a little warm in here that's what
he'd say is it on fire yeah i'll figure
it out i'll figure it out yeah but
that's a nice energy compared to
somebody who oh my god look at you like
yeah yeah you need that sometimes
yeah that's it's uh yeah it'll also keep
it real with you too you know yeah oh
he'll he'll check you right right like
don't get an argument with him about
cars sports or anything if he brings it
up he's done all his research like he
knows everything yeah yeah yeah yeah
um but anyway it was good stuff though i
i still really enjoyed the concert it
doesn't sound like you did but no i love
that i loved watching chen i thought he
was a killer and i thought you could see
how talented little brows was that's
such a shame on the sound yeah i mean i
mean it's the one thing it's like
showing up to a [ __ ] uh swim brace
and there's no water you know it's like
how do you not have good sound also how
do you not have mark harley up there
without a shirt why are you wearing a
shirt i thought you could rip your shirt
off too right yeah looking back and i'm
like i should have done something at
like if this weren't a tank talker
something silly to be like haha here i
am now now now i've said this before we
started rolling but i couldn't be
happier with your arms can you be more
specific well i'm going to get this i'll
tell you why i like them what are you
well they're so i'll tell you what i
like yeah they're super juicy this
morning did you hit did you hit your
arms this morning no we're working out
after this
yeah we we're usually working out right
now oh i did hit back this morning
though at six a.m and then i'm gonna go
work out again hey jeff dies the best
jump because you know mark's wearing
that shirt with a fight crane he goes is
is your mom an anaconda
um
oh [ __ ] i haven't called jeff you're
supposed to be on fire in the kid today
he was yeah i forgot we're not going oh
he's not awake that kid likes sleeping
yeah he didn't get the memo huh so now
now you uh you worked your back but you
also that you incorporate your biceps
and i was just gonna say to you i don't
do that much direct arm work because
i feel like some guys get obsessed with
making their arms bigger and it looks
stupid that's one of the first things
where you're like you know your arms are
too big you don't need that big of
biceps and triceps well your arms
couldn't be big i know what i'm saying i
don't need them to be bigger some guys
you'll it's a thing in bodybuilding
where guys get into it and they start to
look better and then they take certain
aspects of it too far be like hey you
lost the plot of this being like an
aesthetic endeavor yeah and
you looks now i know i could look
borderline silly in many articles of
clothing but
i tried
i tried to keep my eyes on like uh i
don't you know your arms are a lot
bigger than brennan shops yeah for sure
hey real quick how many weeks you think
before you [ __ ] mart
cause he's getting listen dude he's on
social media he's gonna be here every
day okay you gotta stop you gotta stop
he he's gonna look like that every day
but am i gonna [ __ ] him or is he gonna
[ __ ] me and if he does what do i need
poppers
you're clearly the power bottom well i i
would imagine right your power bottom
but i don't think you're you're throwing
it back daddy i'm throwing power power
bottom i'm an old man so i got to do my
poppers you can't get enough you're not
throwing that ass back mark you working
with a piece
uh
i'll answer i've seen it oh really
my guess is he's got matches his arms
daddy he's got there you go and again
i asked question is your mama and
anaconda yeah yeah is that big you know
the real question you have to ask like a
guy who's muscular the the real you know
get to the point what they're not going
to do baby right well because they're
trying to keep you know i try to take
hcg regularly but the real question with
your piece is is it at least
proportionate yeah you don't want it to
be disproportionately small yeah you
don't be shack yeah you don't want to be
like you know
because that's a cliche right the other
thing the other thing is if the other
thing and you can vouch for this mark
and i'm not saying
that it's facts but when you do do uh
like steroids and stuff your nuts go oh
you don't need us so mark's nuts are the
size of blueberries right you know is
that right if i had never taken a big
trunk
um but no
that's a very common thing that the
atrophy would be the word luckily you
can reverse that but if you don't take
the things to reverse it every few
months or whatever
um because you want to fire them up you
want to keep them tested
if you take hcg in clomid like let's say
every two to three months and that's
kind of like you align it with there's
this concept of blasting and cruising
you bump up your dose for
you know two months then you drop it
down for a month and it's you're still
might be on trt but you're taking 18
clomid to uh to restart your so you
don't need that my man here grandfather
clockwise right yeah oh yeah
daddy got some big old no yes
that's what i have right now you don't
need don't don't know brian has heavy
reds your nuts will never quite be that
big if you start no brian brian you you
ever seen like those great danes like
like those big great like you're like
god get your nuts out of my face
great day nights it's just that checks
out heavy and my head just hangs heavy
too now you know you know what brian's
nuts look like an old satchel like a
like an indian purse holding just two
coconuts yeah yeah that's just a leather
yeah old leather wrinkly purse that's
just yeah so why would you want to why
would you want to undermine that that's
a special thing i don't but i also want
i want traps and i want delts but yeah
hey would you rather have traps and
delts and be jacked or in smaller nuts
or have that big old
you know
navajo indian purse hanging between your
legs traps and delts well but i got a
lot of energy still and and daddy's dick
can still cut a diamond so i don't want
to [ __ ] with you yeah i'm at five five
five five now when i hit 6-0 and things
are bad six so yeah let's just get it
next month
in two months when i'm 60 uh or 65
whatever it is yeah then then daddy's
going to get on now i want to talk to
you about your scheduling yeah we're
here at 9 00 a.m everybody's face is
very bloated jim had a
performance last night didn't get home
to probably 1am okay that's a problem
and then you go
hey guys i forgot okay let's talk about
this hey guys i forgot this is what it's
like to work with brian count love you
love you and i've you know i've made it
work sure no problem sure no problem but
also my workout for your curveball
he goes i forgot i i have a flight
tomorrow this is on tuesday i have a
flight tomorrow can't do the pod i go
interesting where are you headed you go
denver yeah and i said will you shoot
your special on thursday is this the
smartest movie oh i booked it a while
ago not smart
not smart
not smart but i will get my reppin
that's like a a starting nfl quarterback
before the super going you know what
dude i'm just gonna dip out the hawaii
the night before the game and i'm gonna
fly right back i'm gonna wake up early
and not get a lot of sleep yes come on
then i'll sleep sitting up and what the
thing about planes they don't dehydrate
you or make you feel like [ __ ] either
but i just do a whole bunch
and i'll be ready to rock thursday
thursday at least it's two shows you
empower through it i'm gonna kill it
yeah i'm gonna kill it i couldn't be
more excited and i think it's the
funniest thing i've ever done
the best stuff i've ever it better be it
is i think it's the best thing i've ever
done of course it is
and the good news is i'll just take it
and [ __ ] cut it up and
do my thing
i'm excited
i'm excited that's the plan uh are you
going to uh you know you're going to
philly everyone i know i didn't know
about the special until we already
booked it i know i booked it a while ago
too yep
i said i'm like i really want to go to
brian special and you're like because
then you made the decision you're like
oh no no now i really want you to
affiliate yeah oh [ __ ] i was i was like
do not go to ryan
you're doing helium one of my favorite
clubs of all time one of my favorite
cities of all time i know i can't wait
so that's the way we do that dude we got
this videographer what's his name his
name's alistair mcdonald which i had to
know and he re so i booked a video so
you know how to do a bit for each city
and so i needed a videographer so i put
on my instagram i actually booked one
through christa stefano who who he has
used before
and then this guy reached out was like
hey man i know you guys booked it but
this is what i do i'm perfect for the
gig i've worked with other comics before
he like tells us all this stuff and then
i was like
he was so passionate i'm like you got it
dude you're in
this dude is mr philadelphia he
it might be vince papali
as a troll i don't know because he knows
he was like i know every restaurant the
local restaurants the local pubs the
places you want to go that are going to
be open i know the references you want
to go to like sneaker shopping clothes
shop like it was like i got you man he's
on board yeah he is a beast videographer
videographer yeah no no videographer
videographer so it's not videographer
it's video
uh so you go vidi video i d-e
videographer
videographer not a videographer yeah
videographer yeah they're just little
things yeah yeah
yes sir
yeah this guy is on it
yeah i'm excited because he not only was
like oh i can i can help him with the
local references he works with
restaurants i guess so he's already
sending me like all these like we're
gonna you know i'm ecstatic because
we're good to set it up so like there's
no thinking about in that stuff we're
gonna see the best parts of philadelphia
and he was like i kind of specialize in
taking people who had a bias towards
philadelphia his friends would visit him
and be like man i thought philadelphia
sucked but after you showed me these
parts of me see i already love
philadelphia it's one of my favorites
can i ask you a question yes
what i'm going to get excited what shoes
are you going to pick me up at suplex
that's not for you dad the jordans
ten and a half hey hey can i ask you
this yeah are you wearing sandals on
your special they're not sandals these
are my toe holds those though yeah those
sandals however you want the flops
you're gonna wear flip flops on stage
i'm not gonna wear flip flops okay i
didn't know no no no no no
no and you're being like you're not
taking this you're being shitty i feel
like you're not [ __ ] ready i'm going
to wear i'm going to wear these jeans
probably maybe maybe some maybe some
lucky brand black jeans
definitely a black
classic now here's the problem you said
uh lucky like it's
a good pair of jeans right yeah but
those are those aren't good but you know
daddy daddy doesn't they don't make a
big difference on daddy's legs i like
those were those pages these are lucky
okay
um
that's the question you know
maybe long you can go the kermit the
frog sweater
no
this yeah no no i like that it's good i
sweater i'll sweat i need i just i swear
daddy needs a t-shirt um or a long
sleeve and then i will do um
golden golden brown juicers yeah i like
those yeah uh i bought a new pair oh
what color they're green and white i'll
show you love it yeah i already like the
color combo now
here wise what are we thinking
now
now we have uh out here
hmu do we have hmu we don't hear makeup
we don't we have hmu no but listen now i
don't like who's doing hmu i don't like
the way you're i don't like the your
question because i think you're being
shitty no because you're going like this
with your head now listen up hey hmu
dude
now in the biz hmu's i don't know what
to say [ __ ] it is man
part of what i'm gonna do is probably
wig
no i'm going to get a little mascara i'm
going to do a little i'm going to have
to darken this area because otherwise it
looks like i got there are some issues i
got to do i might i might i might dust
it a little on top so you can't see much
oh i like that you know what i mean tell
just tell the agency
now knowing you i would assume there's
no hmu at the event there was no hmu at
the i was asked if i needed some and you
said no before i just i remember when
you and i were i forget we were doing
some on fox sports and they go uh do you
guys want what makeup and i go yeah you
go absolutely not i was like you
probably do though huh i probably should
just run a brush yeah you got it i mean
but
do you did you do a little hmu yeah yeah
yeah for especially yeah well because i
don't want to be shiny on i don't want
to look amateur
like i uh the only thing i care about is
like being shiny yeah you want to give
up matt you want to be mad yeah because
it just looks unprofessional i'll uh
look like [ __ ] i'm out with them i'm
actually going to do that you should
i'll get somebody just in case
just have somebody there yeah and if
they get dusty
shiny dude this is just spitball you
know nobody's listening let's just
spitball somebody listening i don't
think so okay what about some eyeliner
i'm not john depp yeah i ain't daddy
ain't just
a couple bracelets a couple rings on the
finger
no i can't do that either dude call your
special i am johnny depp and then come
dressed as [ __ ] jacksonville idea be
so busy such a good idea i ran that by
rogan yesterday i go i want to call the
special joe rogan do i have your
permission he said absolutely not he
started laughing
that would be hilarious it's so stupid
he laughed and then he
and then he shunned you well i've been
i'm changing the subject
i've been glued to my youtube watching
amber heard same cross-examination can't
get dude the lawyer is a seven well when
you get cross-examined
oh but remember that one hey b remember
that a week though to go over her
testimony and go okay we'll poke some
holes in this a week
usually you don't have a week so i had a
week so that's what they were saying
that uh lawyer that expert was like it's
actually gonna help johnny depp because
his defense has a week to
poke holes in whatever the [ __ ] you're
saying my lawyer one time said the good
news is for anybody telling the truth
you're telling the truth and so you have
to remember one story correct when you
tell lies you got to remember all the
stories yeah and keep that same energy
and consistency yep good luck we're
going to ask you those questions over a
million ways yes a million ways can we
get catchy laughs yeah like did you see
a long story yep now now let's let's get
let's see if we can poke some holes now
unfortunately a lot of times you don't
get to put somebody on the stand in this
case johnny got to put her on the stand
and did you see the thing where she said
she donated the divorce settlement no i
played the charity i judged it but 13
you 13 months do you see 13 months the
prosecution goes uh so hold on you said
you in a in multiple interviews you said
you pledged the 8 million to this
foundation yeah and she goes yeah well
my
no very simple
did you actually give eight million
dollars she goes i have the intention to
actually but she said you did but all
they're doing is just
showing like well now the biggest
complete social you've never known them
not to wear big bulky rings on every
finger there's jack sparrow okay he's
never not worn big bolty rings on every
buck he brings on every finger now
but he hits you repeatedly in the face
she said yeah and you lost count on how
many times he hit you in the face
with rings okay
and here are the pictures
your face doesn't have a
marshmallow she's doing this and she has
like a bruise on her head
and then her face looks like you didn't
eat enough iron that day and so you got
a little your face is a new wallet a
dresser yeah now dude you and i know i i
know a little something about violence
if if you're punching somebody with
rings in the face i promise you if
you're slapping somebody i promise you
well that we're gonna get skin gets
opened up oh dude doesn't mean cutting
it's gonna leave couple marks well that
that was my argument with chels with
chael soden thing like when i read the
the
the
kind of the rundown from the victim yeah
and uh man goes yes he uh repeatedly
punched me in the face and held me on
the ground
and then the wife goes yes he repeatedly
punched me in the face and i saw a
picture i'm like
no nobody has any bruising there's no
cuts you know what chill sonnen can do
to your face sir i want to be like uh
real quick i'm just gonna
maybe hit you in the face uh did you see
him fight anderson silva
okay okay
he he punches and elbows super hard he
was a pro i'd go yeah so it was in the
hallway of the four seasons repeatedly
punching an elbow in the face uh did you
see his fight against nate marcotte
who's a killer
you didn't okay no that makes sense okay
yeah no i believe you i believe nate's
assuming i believe he's gonna date a
pushover yeah i believe you
that makes sense very very well the best
men to ever do it repeatedly punching
the face you have
no knicks
that makes sense but she kept saying
that amber heard kept saying that and i
was like and then you hear the video and
you hear that it's like yeah i hit you
johnny okay i was hitting you i don't
know what i was doing with my hand well
that was after he hit me and i was
no no no that's not i'm sorry
this is making no sense but what about
when she if you're all marked up i got
you me too i [ __ ] got you but then
what about her throwing the vodka bottle
cutting his finger off and then his
laura's like well he never said it's
like hey guys we have it on video did
you hear her excuse for how he cut his
finger because i caught that part
specifically i didn't realize that there
was a counter accusation like she
totally denies that she said that there
was an antique phone on the wall in this
apartment this house in australia that
he repeatedly smashed to smithereens
like over and over and over again until
it just broke down like until it's on
the floor and that cut his finger off
like during the smashing
and then
the prosecution goes so here's a picture
like where this area is and she goes
well yeah that that would be uh
the person standing in front of the
where the phone be okay here's another
picture from another angle well yeah
that it would be out of camera
because there's no there's no picture of
the remnants of that there's no
picture anywhere of that phone and
another picture here there's another
phone that would have been like what
you're describing four feet away from it
nobody else can confirm the story nobody
else can confirm the existence of this
antique phone on the wall so it seems
like she just made this thing up like
anything else there they're going to be
they're going to be a lot of holes one
of the things i think is really
interesting
look
men and women fight differently they do
a lot of times and some sometimes they
fight exactly the same but um jimmy
burke was telling me a great story about
how he's he's he gets in a fight
basically he's with his aunt he's with
his mom
and he's with uh his girlfriend
and so it's just him and the bouncer is
being or the door guy the guy who's
running the place is being a real dick
because he just wanted to bring a chair
over for his aunt to sit because she's
elderly and he goes you can't take that
chair you're blocking things he's really
rude and jimmy's kid from brooklyn goes
well okay but you can talk to me a
little differently i'm here with you
guys yeah i don't care you'll be
respectful man and jim goes well well no
hold on hold on you can't he goes
uh move the chair and so the guy's being
so now jimmy's now jimmy goes well i'm
not gonna move the chair now we have a
problem mm-hmm so now the last guy gets
in jimmy's face jimmy gets in his face
and it's getting it's getting spitty
it's getting sick give me a roaster too
but good he'll light you up he'll light
you up but good because what jimmy will
do oh he'll have the whole room laughing
oh yeah because jimmy's going so
embarrassing the guy goes we can take it
outside or something and jimmy goes no i
would never do that you look like you
can bench a lot you look muscular and
he'll do this
you looked i like you bench a lot yeah a
lot and he looked funny yeah so he and
he's very animated
you have to laugh yep so now another guy
comes now now you got two guys in his
face and and
his girlfriend mom and auntie two bogeys
are afraid in the biz we call it bogey
yeah and now jimmy's get now it's
getting a little chubby oh yeah it gets
it gets handsy
handsy
and out of nowhere
jimmy's aunt faints
and all of a sudden holy [ __ ]
you know and because it literally is
about to get into a real fisticuffs she
faints tell me she did on purpose she
faints
and i'm like holy [ __ ] and they're like
jesus said and they have to call the
ambulance they call the ambulance the
paramedics get there everybody's like
help me out now the bouncers are like oh
jesus let us help you they get her in
the chair
and it's like holy [ __ ] and then the
ambulance is there and she goes i'm fine
i'm fine and then she's doing one and
then conflict and mom goes no no and
jimmy goes
we're getting you in the ambulance i
don't i don't know it could be your
heart she goes jim i'm fine and his mom
goes jim she's fine all the women and my
my my mother was there they fight
smarter they go like this they go she
was faking it yeah i go huh de-escalated
she [ __ ] faked the the faint oh me my
genius genius but i didn't i didn't
that's not i didn't pick up that
situation very high social iq there yes
very smart because he was about to get
rocked you'll love this i got it from
you me my girl she'll be arguing right
and she's shouting i'll just go
[Applause]
she can't help but laugh that's a great
way to do it
i just stayed for a solid minute just
i stole this from artie lange that's
already lang's joke because artie lang
used to do this thing where he'd go he'd
talk about like a lot of guys and so in
hollywood of course what what happens is
people come to hollywood in their 20s
they're fantastic they're good-looking
everything else and hollywood will bend
your back and by the time you're in your
40s you're doing a job you don't want to
do and you're back and you look like
you've got the posture of a jumbo shrimp
right you're just bent and that's just
what acting and what this business will
do to you it's going to break you down
yep and um already already would do that
he'd always do this character where you
talk to some guys and they have they
faint because they're so they're so
appalled it's how their life turns out
it always starts with this yeah no
things are good i got a couple things in
the in the works i got actually a
project that i'm i'm working on with uh
what clint eastwood read this
hey just going
is it defenseman
because your life is way too no no no no
no yeah i think no i'm driving this car
right now because my car right now is in
the shop but i i'm actually driving it's
such a good la thing too dude it's it's
it's not the ultimate possum move you're
just like awesome move like your life is
too easy
my girl is she's latin she's at the
height of yamaha
yeah that's just de-escalated
this is because my girl and his girl his
girl uh luanna is from germany yeah
should i have said her name deutschland
yeah
deutsche she is and
by the way she's got abs that girl
she'll love being brought up that girl
is
yeah
and you don't get a better body i mean
you just don't yeah she's not according
to her she thinks she's obese well she's
out of her mind because she's got body
dysmorphia we all have many women are
body this morning hold on no she's got
abs and
not that i was looking but her ass does
it get better than that
i'm you know
i tell her this all the time i'm like do
you realize as you look in the mirror
and say that you were a fat cow
i could probably find a thousand women
in the greater los angeles area who
would murder a homeless person if they
could get away with it and have your
body like that 100 percent i just have
to stab him to death okay yeah yeah and
nobody finds out
i don't know how she grew up a lot of
that's childhood trauma stuff like that
yeah that there is a lot she's also
she's also german like i like i i met
her and my girl and her got along
famously i guess we're gonna have dinner
and stuff they're gonna hang yeah but uh
like i i said i look at her i'm just
looking at this hot girl and i go hey
i'm brian she goes i've met you i was
like sorry i didn't recognize where did
you guys be drift maybe at the improv in
the green room or something yeah yeah
yeah that's right that's what it is yeah
my only uh german i just see are you
schneizer yeah that means oh [ __ ] she
loves that yeah
speaking of fights she looks like she
does not take any [ __ ] what do you guys
fight about what would you say you fight
with your girlfriend shorter list might
be what we don't fight about what's that
a shorter list might be what we don't
fight about yeah um
but
no most certainly uh she's you know has
no problem engaging in confrontation
which really comes in handy for example
when you need like a customer service
issue taken care of it's like you got
like a pit bull on a leash it's like all
right let's go here let him go like your
girl is getting up about you're not
world star chick-fil-a i don't feel like
you fight
oh mark well why you don't
oh you don't you just you don't know
mark right you don't know him very well
mark will fight oh really
i think just
all forms of conflict but it's like i'm
going to make my decision to do that i
would like to avoid like
again i i really think of myself as
i want to be polite and kind to all
people
but if you're going to be a dick you're
going to make threats you're going to
you know like i've
been arrested for fighting before only
in self-defense
i i say the same thing i'm your
huckleberry i've never met a fighter if
you want to argue i'm i'm for it all day
dude yeah that's i come from that my dad
my brother we will argue all day it's
just what we like to do
yeah i'm down for it yeah i've
remembered a fight i don't like to argue
with but you know i was talking to my
therapist he's like well a lot of like
your issues come from like your delivery
dude like with your girl with it whoever
you're delivering that's right he was
like
like i would show him texts like your
delivery dude like there's no context in
the we have no idea like read that out
loud well i won't text with you if we're
having an argument i call you because
otherwise it's going to get
i get
vicious in touch let's start vicious i
go now i got a call but otherwise we're
going to be there's no contact
so it's you know but even
like that's probably an issue with my
girl like you just you know
she doesn't come from that world but you
know as a boss and like you know you're
imagining all this stuff like you got to
be very direct as a boss or whatever you
want to sound real yeah be very direct a
to b i'm not trying to go a you know x y
z and b i want a to b so you want to cut
the fat just like you want to do in a
joke
in life though that can come off really
harsh and so i'm working with that with
my therapist yes yeah and i think it's
good to learn like the opposite of what
your instincts are if you're if you come
if you're naturally harsh maybe learn
how to be more diplomatic and people
often especially women like jordan
peterson talks about the you know
whatever the wage gap is a lot of it
probably has to do with negotiation
because women tend to be not comfortable
with advocating for themselves and
speaking bluntly yeah well also as my
therapist says you have
two ears and one mouth for a reason
right
that's right you have double the hearing
less talking yeah that drives me crazy
and then i talk you know oh you like to
trust me i said crazy don't don't talk
to me that way i went like this drives
me quick i'm already mad all right well
shut the [ __ ] up right yeah he goes
delivery i go not bad though right
getting better because i kind of laughed
at the end
thanks about the two years into one
mouth i do math too
not helpful yeah you're driving me crazy
but you just say listen more right yeah
and don't get talked to me like a
three-year-old because i'm paying for
this i had a boss who used to do he
would go like this if people were making
noise or if you were doing a bad job he
would go i'm using boss slightly uh he's
a guy who runs a lot of things and he
goes like this he goes hey um can you be
loud louder please louder or he'd go
like this he goes is there any is it
possible to do this worse is it possible
to do this actually worse or
because if you could get it you know and
he just does that and leaves you with
that leaves the responsibility to you
yeah i heard somebody say this about
about running a company say how do you
find good employees he goes i make good
employees
he goes i what i'll do is i'll he had a
guy was a problem but he was talented
and so he goes okay let me see what i do
he goes he took him on a [ __ ] with
his wife he takes him on a trip
to vegas
because he knew the guy had talent
takes him on a trip to vegas
takes him on to dinner takes him to a
show and at dinner in front of his wife
he goes he goes hey listen
i want to thank you man i just wanted to
bring you here because you're worth it
and i think that you might be the future
of this company and i need guys like you
and i'm going to hang a lot of
responsibility on you and i want to do
this in front of your wife because it's
going to be a team effort for you guys
if you can't handle it you got to let me
know now but i took it to vegas because
i actually believe in you and if you
can't do this i'd like to know now so
that we can do this but i'm going to
hang a lot of responses did that guy
steal money from the guy [ __ ] became
a great employee oh gotcha got him kind
of [ __ ] together okay sometimes though
sometimes people will go i can't do this
and they'll find a reason to [ __ ] out i
got a piece so bad
i was gonna say uh man
that's an interesting uh outfit that
he's wearing it's a
i don't like his jacket
i was trying to figure out what it was
like what the elements are coming up
this guy entrepreneurs and car he runs
this youtube channel called
entrepreneurs and cars
it's like an interesting you know sort
of like male themed self-help page but
he
uses the because he owns a business and
he talks about uh hiring slow and firing
quick or whatever you know yeah version
of that is and how it's like
if somebody's like proves themselves to
be
a bad employee in some way or whatever
you
gotta get it yeah get it out of there
really quickly well that's the pareto's
principle you've ever brought as
principal 80
of your productivity is created by 20 of
your employees yeah and 80 of your
problems is is created by 20 of your
employees your customers and a lot of
times it's it's
90
or 95 of your problems are caused by
three percent of your customers and
employees tim ferriss talks about that
in the forum and i was like oh that was
a good because he takes you through like
well that's probably just exactly
i think an economist who was gardening
with peas and he found that 20 percent
of his pea shoots created 80 percent of
the piece yeah um and so and if you look
at that that's that's a principle that
you can cut across like like a very
small number of musical composers
produce most of the music right yeah uh
and and so it and so it goes it's a very
small group the bigger question is how
do you and what do you do about people
that can't
necessarily compete for the rest of the
the ten percent of the spoils uh you
still talking about business no we're
talking about like pareto pareto's
principle you know we're where if you
run a company um it'll be like five or
ten percent of your employees cause nine
percent of your problems yes and also
like twenty percent of your employees
create eighty percent of your profits so
they'll always say like if you have an
employee if you have a customer that's
causing taking up 80 of your time yeah
get rid of them get rid of them not
worth it get the [ __ ] out of here yeah i
think with with thick bone we have you
know we have our meeting every monday
about this it's like the way i run it
here a lot of people and i've talked to
you about this
a lot of guys it's happened with some
comics too because with our job
it's a lot of fun
there's a ton of fun when you're on the
road and then when you're in here it's
super creative and there's like art on
the you know the walls and like it's a
good environment
and i'm not
and i tell all these guys i'm not the
boss like you have to make decisions and
it's coming out of my you know my salary
to pay for everybody else's salary but
i'm not a bot like it's a team thing
like you know me i come from team team
sports yeah so it's all about the team
so
you know the way i would there's no team
but keep going yeah i'm in hot but [ __ ]
hollywood i'll create and you're in
comedy there's no team keep going
there's not but i can create as close as
i can to team atmosphere you've been
trying for a year i've been trying for a
very long time
so with think boy which you know i
create this team here
the better so
for example think more youtube the
better the youtube shows do
everybody has a piece of it so as as the
the
the business grows everybody grows so
it's a great business yeah so they have
incentive to to work and and then i'm
not in here going hey man are you
getting this done and getting this done
it's on you so i tell motivation yeah so
it's like it's on you dude and there's
been guys that don't fit and they need
somebody over their shoulder tell them
what to do all the time this ain't the
place for you if you're not
self-motivated to get better and and put
creative content out and come up with
ideas this just isn't for you well i get
a kick out of youtube because is there
anybody worse at firing anybody than
brendan like brendan just can't do it
you you
throughout the 10 years i've known you
i'd rather go broke you'd rather hurt
somebody he'll pay somebody he will pay
somebody for three years yeah and a real
salary before he and this this is by the
way this is not
this is not a talk about we're not
talking about cat at all or anybody like
is not but but but there have been
employees in the past and not into no
fault of their own but it's like i've
said to you i've been like i i don't
know what this person what's going on
here there's a lot of money going on i
don't know i know you go i know but i
can't i don't know how to fight no my
the best the best is i'll call you and
rent too he ran and i'm like tomorrow
i'm firing him and then 20 minutes go by
go brian you know how this can go down
you know how you go i'm gonna do nothing
and i'm gonna keep paying them and lose
money that's how my life really a half
hour talk an hour talk and i go now
here's the thing um we're going to go
tomorrow and we're not going to say
anything to that person we're going to
keep them on for another two years and
that's how it is you know this is
exactly how it's going to work i go
you're right so i'll see you tomorrow
backbone and nobody can fire anybody and
it's the way it is it's rough although
you know i'm going gonna say i'm gonna
i'm gonna this is a compliment to
adam
um to to will ferrell and to adam um
mckay
uh i don't know them well at all i i've
i've i did one movie with them but um i
remember when
there was a [ __ ] uh i did a reading
with them
and this is how nice adam mckay and will
ferrell is think about this think about
how good these are these are such good
people
there was an act a certain actor at the
reading who i have on good authority was
just not good they were just they
weren't working for the part they were
good they just were wrong for the movie
they were wrong for the party but it was
just it was a real part a substantial
part okay and everyone knew this and the
studio and the producers were like it's
just not there's a better choice out
there
and adam mckay and will ferrell
we're like i know but we just can't fire
too mean
it's too they don't even know the person
that well they're like it's too mean
this business sucks and we don't have
the heart and i when i heard that um and
i heard that from a third party but i
believe them because they shouldn't they
knew better they knew but i really
really respect that no adam and will
aren't friends anymore oh no because of
that show on hbo the uh l.a laker show
will thought it was so adam wrote that
if you haven't seen that series it's
[ __ ] phenomenal wow on hbo it's the
lakers now they're getting sued because
they didn't get the the
light likeness and all that [ __ ] from
the lakers so they're getting sued
whatever but adam uh wrote that movie or
i'm sorry i wrote that uh series and
will ferrell thought he was a shoe-in to
play uh the boss family oh you know to
play to play the owner yeah and they
went with his buddy from step brothers
uh john c o'reilly
and uh i guess uh adam was like didn't
want to tell will but he thought john c
reilly was perfect for it and will was
assuming that was his role and then he
found out through like
you know la times that he's not getting
their gig that's very strange they
haven't talked since how would you have
handled it both of you
well i will say this about i would have
wrote will a different i would be like
all right how about you play jerry west
where
the thing about jerry west is the guy
who plays jerry west he looks like me so
good
i even though this is the way i work
even though
will doesn't look like jerry west to say
to salvage that friendship i would have
put him in no matter what they're like
yeah maybe doesn't look like him we can
give him a nose job or something like
that but i i would have done that
because i to lose a friendship over that
is not fair he'll deliver i don't know
what the situation was no but but that's
so you funny or die they did all that
[ __ ] together they do not speak
and adam mckay came out in the ark was
like i feel terrible i i've reached out
to will he just won't respond he's so
upset about it it's been like three
years
that's really he's a sensitive guy i i
do know this about will ferrell i've
heard um from people who know him well
and i th he's a obviously a great person
one of the greats insanely competitive
like insane oh interesting apparently i
want to get that from if you play golf
with him
i've just heard from people like like
it's shocking how competitive
interesting shocking like he is
sometimes that's annoying it's it's
it's exhausting sometimes someone like
will who's clearly a very good person
but also so [ __ ] like i know people
my old manager saw will before he was
famous in a sketch show and he was like
watching this guy the guy was so
unbelievable he was like but his his
commitment
to be great in this tiny little theater
was just astonishing and he goes oh well
he's going to be he tried to sign him
right there he couldn't he was like he's
going to be the biggest thing ever he
could just tell but he
part of what makes him
so good is that every single role he
does he's going to make you remember him
if you remember what got him to the game
if you remember like old school and
these old school he was so committed to
this like streaking everything he did
was amazing and the little roles he
would play in any of those movies and so
i think that that that is a kind of
mindset that is win at all costs and
then if you get [ __ ] over in your mind
and you don't win at something it's very
hard to readjust it's a it's a tough way
to live yeah and it gets very lonely
because if someone shades you just a
little bit and they've been your friend
for 30 years
people make mistakes right so when you
get to the top
let me ask you this my guess is
that over 30 years there was
this was you know what this was the
straw the camel's back thank you that's
what i think thank you who might read
that go don't make sense yeah over one
role yeah how many roles does will
ferrell get offered yeah over this this
is your boy this was the final slight of
some kind this was this feels like it
was i
this feels like enough enough yeah but
it's let's say you were doing a comedy
buddy movie yeah and there was a role
for an athletic funny dude and you
booked somebody else yeah i would be
super hurt yeah i would call him like
dude really
you know what i don't know if i'd do
that yeah i'll talk [ __ ] to you to mark
and my brother behind your back
but i wouldn't come to you and for a
confrontation but i can't believe
eventually it would come out where i'm
like really you don't think i could do
that really and we'd make a joke out of
it and i'll have deep resentment but i
wouldn't ruin our friends no no we'd
figure it out yeah because part of being
cause you could have me if i'm wrong
part of being real close friends is
going bad on each other behind each
other's backs sometimes but but bad but
not bad i don't know i mean like no no
yeah like roasting like yeah
like gossip like you believe you know
yeah
but if i was doing a if i was doing a
podcast and somebody went bad on you
in front of me i'm gonna rip your head
off oh no no yeah yeah we're gonna have
a problem oh yeah yeah no we're never
probably yeah it was like it was like it
was like uh when when it been and also
somebody who's i really respect like i
some dude on i told you i did this radio
show and the guy was kind of an amateur
comic and he was going bad on
right wing comic quote-unquote
right-wing comic
jim brewer he was he was referring to
jim brewer as right wing now jim
brewer's wife and has has cancer or is i
believe in his in remission and jim
brewer was talking about how crazy this
mask stuff was for him because he's real
he's trying to live his life and he's
like he's not going to live in fear and
jim has a very emotional reason and
philosophy behind it but when i heard
this [ __ ] going bad on [ __ ] i
remember that was great you called me
after you got a great jim brewer
top five guests all the time on fire i
couldn't let it go top five dude he's
such a stand up i used to watch his
special so much with the uh the one the
metallica like he's a mom you've seen
them oh disease
[ __ ] beautiful monster went into all
the drinks mixing in the stomach that
one he's like he's beautiful
monster
very few people make me laugh that hard
i mean i've been watching him before
like in new york when we were doing the
comic strip i mean that guy has never
not crushed him so i got some dude i got
some dude saying he's not funny i was
like you know what i was gonna be you
know i'd have done i've been like that
attitude right there is why you're never
gonna make it oh my god right there have
you ever heard me have you ever heard me
i kept going back to it
uh even from high to low never say
anything about any kind of never never
you're never gonna you're counting
insane material that guy's come up with
oh but just and then we can take stand
up out of it saturday night live go go
boy one of the most infamous characters
and see how funny it is have him on a
podcast and watch how what a monster
here how long been podcasting top five
correct we've he is a title we might
even give him top three
that's fair i mean
i mean yeah top five let's go top five
five yeah yeah but in the running for
number one in the running for number one
so good i'm gonna have a problem and uh
you know so he's so [ __ ] universal
too because i was gonna say when people
pigeonhole you in this it is unfortunate
when it's like you're adding these
qualifiers it's like are you aware of
his reputation it's also because he's
such a good person it's also because
nobody says anything bad about jim
brewer because he's a [ __ ] great
person yeah he's being and it really
sucks great things trump that when he
created oh you disagree with me
we joke around how you know we'll go
about each other behind each other's
back and but it's all like harmless [ __ ]
yes
delay there mark freaked out
lunch somebody came in a couple of
people came in beat him up around we got
in a little fight i have roid rage and
i'm not going to hide that fact because
i want to use myself as an example for
young men out there please don't take
steroids you're taking accountability
mark tasmanian deviled this room
knocked down the cameras went full
cookie monster trademark please
it wasn't true but it is yep chin give
us current events tournaments what do
you got brian catch a flight oh yeah uh
mcdonald's is leaving russia for good no
after 30 years
but that's messed up to the actual
citizens there that don't want any part
of this mcdonald's i feel so bad
so so when they do yeah me too so when
they do this stuff and they take away
like all this [ __ ] from russia putin is
in his
you know putin they don't know how much
he's worth they think he's like top five
richest yeah in the world billionaire
billionaire if you've ever seen this
house it's [ __ ] nuts
putin goes business as usual this
doesn't affect him in any pheasant so
you're taking away mcdonald's hurts the
russian public not poop yeah putin's
your problem not the russian people
sucks for the russians and it sucks for
those russian soldiers they're starving
getting killed left and right they're
out there they're fighting the war they
don't want to be in they're killing
[ __ ] disaster man disaster it's all a
mess
and now they can't even get a [ __ ]
mcflurry yeah
just just when you thought things got
bad
now you can't get a [ __ ] shamrock
flurry a mcflurry now you can't get to
mcrib you think your day's ruined now
those chicken nuggets that deep-fried
snot that you love with sweet and sour
sauce out of here sorry russia
i want to make rib i want mcrib and the
mc a big
we've been talking about arby's recently
right so this particular arby's one of
the employees
peed inside a milkshake thingy hell yeah
uh it's a milkshake mix at the
restaurant it could to sexually gratify
himself that's just something that turns
on turns out this guy is also
suspected of child or distributing child
pornography and everything else okay
this guy's a terrible person what a
surprise let me say you like this pee in
milkshakes because you get off on that
[ __ ] you know people get into that stuff
it's all this weird stuff like i peed in
the milkshake they get off on that it's
like people who break into people's
houses and take a [ __ ] in their closet
yeah but
my thing is i've never tasted piss
i wouldn't be you know
i'd be open to it i guess depending what
they just get off on you have to take a
piece of them in your body yeah but if
it's a vanilla shaking you're pissed in
it i feel like i'd be able to tell you
probably yeah i don't know if well
that's a huge bag depending on how
flavors of poppy was you know what i
mean orange pee you're
you're not going to get sick from it so
it's like all right dude yeah good well
he also confessed to having a quote
unquote sexual interest in children yeah
you
need to go away
yeah so they think at least 30 to 40
people might have actually drank well he
downloaded and shared child porn you
hey you yo
phone call though hey uh mcdonald
and that's in vancouver
you they peed in my milk boy
listen i'm sure we've all tasted some
piss on our fast food oh yeah yeah yeah
that iced tea i'm like you can ask for
an arnold palmer this is weird i love
that
uh what do you guys think of this one oh
this is so distasteful now listen i
don't think you should be canceled or
any of that [ __ ] this is 2011 too yes
this is right after amy winehouse died
for his halloween party he had a [ __ ]
cake made from amy winehouse dead body
now now uh i know neil and he's the
funniest [ __ ] coolest guy on the
planet doogie how's it going yes and i
and and i think that uh he's got a great
sense of humor and sometimes we go a
little too far so i'm going to defend
him on this but that is
so distinctive
what went into that like out of all the
cake options you have you're like amy
winehouse's rotting corp you get it on
elvis and been okay right but amy wants
that but he's months after she dies yeah
but he you would laugh your ass off with
him he's such a funny guy that he just
it's all crazy did he make the call for
the kick though like who actually was
like oh i know and then got approval for
it but somebody originated yeah i'm sure
he has a team right for his party him
and his man yeah
it's that that's just he's he's not good
funny [ __ ] and a really good
person but sometimes he's like get it
it's corpse you know it's just nobody
okay sometimes you want to you want to
push things
oh so this tick tocker she's not that
big but she was she is obviously
she put a vibrate in her butt and then
finally got stuck in there we got a
freak on her hands so she couldn't go to
the hospital the first night so she
tried to sleep but it just kept going
off obviously so she went the next
morning he had to get it surgically
removed i dated a girl who said to me
she goes i'm wearing a butt plug
she's wearing like at dinner she said
she's like here
and she's on the phone with her and she
goes uh i'm wearing a butt plug for you
and i was like
say less you're right yeah i was like
that she put this is this was the
culprit that's naughty what's what's a
butt plug doofer i don't know dude
stretches it before you do anal it's
like you got to stretch it out you know
it's like you got to get limber before
you do a spring it keeps things it's
like it's like what i'm going to wear
around mark because apparently i thought
it was supposed to be brian's wearing
one right now i thought it's supposed to
be for vaginally like it's like
no no no but butt plug
you know what it's like
if you've ever seen a marathon it's like
stretching before you hit the marathon a
lot of guys will see you gonna wear a
butt plug but wouldn't make the [ __ ]
tighter too though because it's like
done i feel sick
i
he said it does no it's like stretching
before tough mudder you don't get muddy
for the purpose of that yes [ __ ] and
you're on point and brendan that's also
accurate you're just stretching the mud
whistle and making sure everything's
clean and also eat salad beforehand you
know all right yeah all right last one
just real quick uh karma lecture is now
now on oli fans she's a good person and
she will be doing she'll be taking off
stuff like she'll be taking off stuff
she'll be definitely like dude does
anybody in here subscribe to only fans
i've never i don't i've never done
nothing no i have never i don't i don't
know what it is
like if you see a girl and think that
it's like and have that it's like ah but
then what go to x video porno you know
there's there's a zillion free porn
but i feel like we should all the i feel
like
the production house should splurge
and get some only fan accounts so we can
speak education
no i think that's yeah just kind of a
collection because we don't know we
don't know if you're logging in whatever
it's just you're like whoever you got to
log in
do your research let's use a let's use a
company credit card yeah we'll just come
up with one let's get a lot of land here
no nothing actually our business
management bank dude on the thick boy
account uh
there is
thousands of dollars spent on we
established a separate company which is
called research house oh i like that and
so recently research yep it's called
research house and we hate doing this
but we have to look at all these to make
sure everything and we go through all
the counts it's like hot girl hot girl
like yeah and then uh someone keeps
buying a monthly uh membership some dude
named big dick dave i'm like that's
brian yeah he's just just for research
well for me it's like when when that
spooky ghost [ __ ] was leaking all the
celebrity photographs of naked women i
made it a point not to look at the
pictures because i was like they don't
if they don't if you're a woman you
don't want me to look at your pictures i
ain't looking at those [ __ ] pictures
right but then i you know you're [ __ ]
doing something and somebody's like look
at this and you end up seeing them
anyway only fans basically patreon for
uh porno stars and they get one-on-one
stuff so you can pay extra and actually
talk to them on video chat and stuff
like that so that's why it's different
than watching and a lot of these women
making a ton of money you don't need
these big like braziers or whatever it
is you know the [ __ ] taxi you're just
taking all the money that you want yeah
support local businesses yeah i thought
that taxi was real for years all right i
was like man that guy always picks up
hot chicks and waits not
[ __ ] down
[Music]
uh
[ __ ] taxi i'm in uh if my only fans is
going on stage um in philadelphia this
week this thursday friday saturday
philadelphia helium let's do it baby
almost sold out philadelphia helium this
thursday friday saturday i'll be
marching around your town listen to meek
mill then los angeles california one
show only at hollywood improv shop and
friends with some monsters with a very
special guest may 25th that's next
wednesday at 8 00 pm
then portland oregon one of my favorite
cities favorite clubs helium in portland
is june 9th through 11th
san francisco
that is cobbs the infamous cobbs where
robin williams used to perform san
francisco's june 17th through the 18th
then san diego and this great club that
just opened up laugh factory san diego
right in the heart of downtown san diego
this is july 21st to the 23rd come do it
with me
july 21st through the 23rd san diego
laugh factory san diego but philly
europe let's ride baby and saturday at
noon i'll be at suplex sneaker shop in
philadelphia we have a collab with thick
boy and suplex merch dad hats and tees
i'll be buying sneakers for the crew
come on out say what's up they have food
giveaways all sorts of cool [ __ ] that's
at suplex at noon on saturday philly see
you soon
thursday that is tomorrow we got my
special tips
we have sold out the first show i think
there are still some tickets left for
the second show at 9 30. come on brea
get it let's go we're going to be packed
it's going to be sick west palm beach
florida may 27 28 29 that's a friday
saturday sunday
west palm beach florida i might one of
my favorite places to perform the improv
richmond virginia funny bone europe june
3rd 4th omaha nebraska funny bone june
10 and 11.
let's go
see you soon is that it that's it all
right kids this the fire kid we're out